we were exclusive backstage where we
caught up with everybody including an
emotional Jennifer right after her big
big Grammy moment this was for your mom
did you lay it off mom I could cry it's
such a good moment it's just so cool
this singing up doing with Smokey
Robinson I got a pinch myself I can't I
grew up on all those songs and because
my mom loved him so much that she passed
them on to us
is this a dream come true
[Applause]
I feel like that performance shut down
any critics or how to who said thank you
yeah you know the thing about music is
that any type of music can inspire any
type of artist you know you can't you
can't tell people with some love I'm
sorry I'm just babbling no no you killed
it you think that was the second time
JLo wild the Grammy crowd last night
she joined Lady gaga Jada pinkett-smith
host Alicia Keys and former First Lady
Michelle Obama in a surprise tribute to
the power of music that left the
audience stunned music shows us that all
of it matters every story within every
voice every note within every song what
a great surprise
[Music]
all right how'd you pull that off
we had to keep it on the low especially
because I forever first lady was here so
for security purposes you had to keep it
low how was it being a part of that
amazing over here it was incredible
I'm having so much fun I feel so blessed
that was before Gaga won a Grammy for
shallow the song she performed with
Bradley Cooper for a star is born
I wish Bradley was here with me right
now I know he wants to be here Bradley I
loved singing this song with you Bradley
and girlfriend arena shakes skipped the
Grammys to be in London so he could
accept a BAFTA Award for the very same
song most of all I have to thank arena
for putting up with me for all the music
I was trying to make in our basement for
a year how was it how did it feel I had
a great time man I love playing music
and I just love everybody in that room
and I was just so happy to think of the
world you know it's a blessing every day
thank you songs are blessing too is it
it's a conversation between a man and a
woman and I think that represents a lot
you know we all in this world we need to
keep talking
check out Gaga's Graham after she won
it's her mood after winning three
Grammys and finally meeting cardi B
cardi made Grammy history as the first
solo female artist to win Best Rap Album
we were right there as she rushed
offstage after her performance our
exclusive backstage spot was in the
middle of the Grammy action
I am beyond honored and excited and
grateful for this crazy moment in my
life Katie how much fun was that
Katie are you gonna go celebrate maybe I
need a carb in my life I want to say the
Mayor of Toronto needs to turn the CN
Tower goal tomorrow I'm chrome and gold
it's a beautiful dignified classy night
of music
[Music]
man I feel unbelievable you're coming
back next year
couples rules from Alicia and Swizz to
cardi B and offset the reconnected pair
held hands the whole night right up to
this unexpected moment when an audience
member fainted a stretcher was rushed in
everything's okay now but an eye witness
tells et people were freaking out like
[Music]
giddy giddy no drama with Shawn Mendes
but he kept playing coy with et first
was Zane Lowe from beets one on Apple
music when he asked about a future
collaboration
what's this room right here about you
and Miley Cyrus committing this creative
relationship to more than just the stage
I guess we'll have to just wait and see
that's the worst poker face I've ever
seen I know I never set out a good poker
face man I'm Justine JLo and a rod na
koi posting about their second
anniversary last Sunday you said that he
makes you feel like a teenager again
does you know we have so much fun
together that it feels like we're
starting life all over again so I feel
like that I love my job is the cameraman
so so all four of them should be
watching my kids star sons were front
and center Ricky Martin's Mateo and
Robin Thicke's eight year old Julian how
excited are you to be here at Dada and
then there was Diana Ross's nine year
old grandson celebrating her upcoming
75th birthday my grandma me Diana Ross I
love my grandma to the bottom of my
heart so I am really excited for
75th birthday he's a star what was that
moment like it's just so great it's all
about the audience
[Music]
[Applause]